merci cher président moi je voudrais
parler des chefs d'entreprises parce que
notre mouvement les républicains doit
être le mouvement qui encourage qui
soutient nos créateurs rappelez vous
cette déclaration de quelqu'un qui
pourtant est de bourgogne franche comté
cette très très belle région dans
laquelle j'ai l'honneur de servir aux
côtés de nos amis centristes
quand monsieur montebourg a dit la
famille peugeot on en a marre et bien
comment monsieur montebourg peut dire la
famille peugeot on en a marre à cette
famille qui a fait de toute sa vie toute
sa vie l'entreprise la création
d'emplois level la valeur ajoutée le
rayonnement mondial de la franche comté
est maintenant de la bourgogne franche
comté je pense qu'aux républicains on
doit absolument réhabiliter l'intérêt
que nous portons aux entreprises dans
notre pays il n'y aura pas d'avenir
il n'y aura pas d'emplois sur les
entreprises alors je sais que c'est une
litote je sais que c'est une évidence
mais je pense que les socialistes ont
oublié ça si nous n'avons pas des chefs
d'entreprise des créateurs et je
voudrais insister sur une chose nous
avons actuellement une nouvelle
génération de créateurs entrepreneurs
sur des nouveaux enjeux et bien cette
nouvelle génération d'entrepreneurs
si nous les laissons partir à l'étranger
nous allons avoir d'énormes difficultés
pour les nouvelles générations et pour
donner des emplois à ces nouvelles
générations
je reviens sur ce qui vient d'être dit à
l'instant on avait fait avec nicolas
sarkozy quelque chose de formidable qui
était la tva compétitivité qui d'un seul
coup d'une manière structurelle et dans
la durée
baisser les charges de nos entreprises
leur redonnait de la compétitivité et
bien qu est ce qu ont fait les
socialistes en arrivant à l'heure où ils
ont fait un mea culpa
enfin il ya le mea culpa et derrière il
n'en tire aucune conséquence ils ont dit
on n'aurait pas dû on n'aurait pas dû
mais il ne la remette pas en place et
bien moi je pense que dans nos régions
nous allons devoir oeuvrer pour faire en
sorte que cette élection régionale l
action que nous allons avoir derrière
elle soit quelque part préfiguratrice de
ce que nous allons faire autour de notre
prochain président de la république pour
redonner l'envié d'entreprendre en
france
la compétitivité et donc la création
d'emplois et ça passe aussi dans la
gestion de nos régions par faire
exactement l'inversé de ce qu'ont fait
les socialistes en quelques temps les
socialistes en bourgogne franche comté
ils ont augmenté la dette de 30 % mais
ont baissé l'investissement de 15 %
cherchez l'erreur ils ont augmenté les
frais de fonctionnement de plus de 30%
en direction des entreprises comme de
bons socialistes ils ont mis en place 47
procédure différente en direction des
entreprises dans le cadre des politiques
publiques nous avons un travail de
simplification à faire de meilleures
gestions bc fonctionnement la relance
par l'investissement la création
d'emplois redonner confiance aux
entreprises aux entrepreneurs à leurs
salariés
et puis un mot pour les jeunes mettons
fin
mettons fin à cette politique en
direction de l'emploi des jeunes qui
consiste à mettre nos jeunes français
dans les collectivités publiques que
l'on retrouve en stage et cinq ans plus
tard un nouveau au chômage alors que
l'on sait que si nous orientons nos
jeunes vers les entreprises
alors que si nous orientons nos jeunes
vers les entreprises
toutes les études montrent que 85 % des
jeunes qui ont une intégration dans les
entreprises dans le privé au bout de
cinq ans sont dans un emploi permanent
et lassante l'ascenseur social se met à
ce moment là en route
en clair c'est assez simple il faut
faire exactement le contraire de ce que
font les socialistes depuis dix ans dans
nos régions
et je voudrais reprend ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure par jean-pierre ils ont
failli en bourgogne franche comté deux
régions socialistes
six départements socialistes sur huit
ils se sont jamais posé la question de
savoir ce qu'ils allaient pouvoir faire
ensemble pour lutter contre le chômage
et créer des emplois nouveaux
je pense sincèrement que l'on peut faire
en région beaucoup plus facilement ce
que l'on ne peut pas faire au niveau de
l'état deux cent mille chômeurs en
bourgogne franche comté c'est quand même
plus facile de s'en occuper que 5
millions au niveau national donc mes
chers amis
retroussons les manches l'espoir est
devant nous et je pense que l'emploi
puisque je rappelle aussi que nicolas
sarko
il a voulu que nous définissions au
niveau national quatre ou cinq grandes
priorités pour les régionales la
priorité numéro un pour les régionales
c'est la lutte contre le chômage et
c'est la création d'emplois autour et à
l'intérieur de nos entreprises
on est vraiment aujourd'hui dans le
sujet donc bonne campagne à tous
nous allons gagner